nothing worse than being a woman in this business
I sometimes wish I was African American
you know okay
so in feminist scholarship there's this idea that oppressions are not ranked
they're linked
which is the idea that you can't really say that like
sexism is worse than racism or racism is worse than sexism
that they're all connected
many black feminist scholars will say that their blackness right
their experience of racism is actually the the
the hardest part of their experience more than their womenness
this because they
they don't just experience racism
they experience a modified
more pernicious uh
version of racism
which is modified by the sexism that they experience
this comment doesn't just omit the
you know existence of black women um
it also makes Assumption that somehow
the experience of black women is easier than the experience of white women
which is well documentedly not true
what sort of that said is that she wants to be an African American man
which is unfortunately how a lot of white women come into feminism
wanna be men they want power
not freedom want an individual emancipation and not a collective one